monsieur messieurs les présidents de
commissions et mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs je vous remercie tout d'abord
d'avoir inscrit à l'ordre du jour de vos
deux commissions aujourd'hui mon
audition
et je souhaite donc elles me permettent
de répondre à l'ensemble des questions
et que vous souhaiterez me poser au
préalable je souhaiterais insister sur
la qualité du dialogue que je souhaite
nouer avec avec les assemblées
la haute-assemblée représente les
collectivités locales et revêt donc une
importance toute singulière à mes yeux
puisque la réussite de mon action sera
je le sais conditionné au pacte que nous
serons nous et avec les collectivités
locales
le président de la république et le
premier ministre m'ont confié un
portefeuille ministériel qui est tourné
vers l'avenir
alors c'est un honneur certes mais c'est
aussi et surtout une chance celle de
pouvoir impulser et conduire le
redressement productif de notre pays et
je crois qu'il faut y être attachées
dans une période qui est marquée
actuellement par par des nouvelles qui
sont plutôt moroses et mauvaise des
inquiétudes sur l'avenir de la zone euro
alors avec arnaud montebourg nous sommes
pleinement mobilisés depuis plusieurs
semaines déjà au service de cette
ambition est certes comme je le disais
il ya les urgences à traiter et l'état
est déterminé à sauver les sites
sauvegarder l'emploi préserver le
savoir-faire industriel français est
accompagné ces mutations
mais il nous revient aussi et surtout au
coeur de la crise de préparer à l'avenir
de dessiner les conditions du rebond de
construire les leviers notre
compétitivité et de préparer la
croissance future
les raisons de croire en notre sursaut
en aux entreprises est en notre pays en
ses capacités en notre force
d'entreprendre ne manquent pas j'en ai
chaque jour de nouveaux exemples au
travers de mes déplacements ou de mes
rencontres
mais ma conviction c'est que ce sursaut
suppose que nous poussions notre
avantage là où nous sommes en capacité
de le faire
d'agir là où réside notre intérêt
stratégique là où le retour sur
investissement sera le plus rapide et le
plus efficient pour la france nous
n'avons plus le temps de faire de
mauvais choix les mauvais choix
donc le premier nommé chantier sera
celui des pme pour relever la france et
ses emplois pour relever la france s'est
employé ces entreprises il nous faudra
aider celles qui constituent 90 7 % de
notre tissu économique c'est-à-dire nos
pme je suis là ministre de ses 97 % là
dont on parle si peu et dont on s'occupe
souvent si mal de pme doivent avoir
accès aux financements être accompagné à
chaque étape de leur développement et
être à chaque fois que cela est possible
encourager pour aller vers l'export
quel diagnostic dressons nous au terme
de deux mois de travail et de
consultation tout d'abord les pme
françaises offrent déjà de belles
réussites et je crois qu'il faut s'en
féliciter
certaines d'entre elles ont un
formidable potentiel et des atouts sur
lesquels il faut capitaliser pour autant
nous ne nions pas que leur situation est
très tendue et que de fortes menaces
pèsent sur leurs activités
il ya d'abord des difficultés
conjoncturelles deux crises successives
laisse des traces parfois lourdes et je
sais aussi comme en attestent les
premières remontées de terrain relayée
en particulier par la cgpme et parler le
par les élus également qu'il ya des
signes de tension manifeste sur la
trésorerie
mais il ya aussi des préoccupations plus
structurelle aujourd'hui nous savons les
pme françaises n'est ce petit en
effectifs et en capitaux propres et
peinent ensuite à combler leur retard
pour grandir pour innover pour exporter
c'est pour qu'elles soient en mesure de
poursuivre leur développement sans heurt
y compris à l'international que j'ai
donc annoncé avec arnaud montebourg un
plan pme pour la rentrée je souhaite le
redire ici les pme de notre pays doivent
être soutenus et elles le seront
fortement
je m'y engage ce soutien prendra la
forme dès l'automne d'un plan pme
quels en seront les lignes directrices
et les lignes de force
tout d'abord nous souhaitons briser le
plafond de verre qui fragilise les pme
dans leur expansion et donc nous
proposerons une série de mesures afin de
mieux les accompagner aux différents
stades de leur développement de qu'elle
parle de quel plafond de verre parlons
nous ici de celui auquel se heurtent les
pme parfois dès la première étape si
crucial de leur financement
la création prochaine de la banque
publique d'investissement la bpi
apportera de ce point de vue une réponse
en même temps qu'une sécurité
importantes sur la question essentielle
du financement aucune source ne sera et
ne devra être négligé pour les pme le
rapport de niles euronext de leurs
conclusions ont été dévoilées le 3
juillet dernier sur le projet d'une
plateforme boursière destiné aux aux pme
et aux hautes et ouvre une piste qui
méritera d'être expertisée il nous
faudra aussi améliorer l'environnement
des entreprises sans vouloir tout
bouleverser est tout chamboulé car nous
savons que la stabilité est un élément
important de la confiance que peuvent
avoir les chefs d'entreprise et les
salariés mais en ayant toujours à
l'esprit la volonté de faire réussir nos
pme nous devons donc reprendre pour
mener à bien cette fois ci le chantier
important de la simplification
administrative
il n'est pas possible de continuer à
décourager l'envi d'entreprendre dans
notre pays
un manque de coordination entre
administrations ou par ignorance de la
réalité quotidienne des entreprises
mon message aux pme est donc très clair
tout sera mis en oeuvre pour faciliter
votre activité et votre croissance car
au bout du compte c'est la france qui en
bénéficiera cela passera vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure par une fiscalité adaptée
le poids de l'impôt est aujourd'hui plus
lourd pour les pme que pour les grands
groupes comme l'affirmé le premier
ministre dans son discours de politique
générale les pme doivent donc bénéficier
de dispositifs fiscaux avantageux
je ne sous estime pas la nécessité de
rétablir l équilibre de nos finances
publiques qui sont en très mauvais état
objectifs du gouvernement auquel nous
soucie jusqu'où je souscris totalement
pardon mais ce redressement doit se
faire aussi au plan fiscal sous le signe
de l' équité entre les pme et les grands
groupes
cela passera aussi par une forme de
sensibilité de culture pme dans la
manière de concevoir nos politiques
économiques et de légiférer
chaque mesure chaque texte chaque
décision peut avoir un impact lourd
parfois imprévues sur la vie quotidienne
de nos pme et c'est la raison pour
laquelle je vous proposerai de mettre en
oeuvre un test pme ce test c'est la
garantie d'une action efficace
économiquement nous veillerons ainsi à
ce que chaque nouvelle législation avant
de devenir définitives soit examinée à
la lumière de ses effets sur
l'entreprise et plus particulièrement
sur la petite et moyenne entreprise
voilà donc pour le plafond de verre à
faire sauter le second engagement pris
est de stimuler le réflexe pme et
l'esprit d'entreprise auprès du plus
grand nombre
je veux le dire ici avec force l'esprit
d'entreprise n'appartient à aucune
famille politique je crois que le temps
où cette thématique servait davantage
entretenir des clivages idéologiques
factice plutôt qu'à faire avancer les
entreprises françaises et est amené
canton par réflexe pme d'abord c'est un
meilleur équilibre entre donneurs
d'ordre et sous traitants la sphère
publique devra sur ce plan montrer
l'exemple et je veux bien sûr parler ici
de la commande publique a été évoqué
tout à l'heure par le président on ne
peut pas se satisfaire aujourd'hui de ce
que les pme obtiennent une part des
marchés publics notablement inférieur à
ce qu'elle leur poids dans l'économie
l'état mais aussi les opérateurs et les
collectivités locales doivent conduire
de conserve
c'est important de concertation et cette
importante réflexion stimuler le réflexe
pme c'est provoquer ce déclic
entrepreneuriale dans le pays afin qu'il
soit en mesure d' innover d'exporter et
finalement de créer les emplois de
demain
j'ai confié il ya quelques jours à
monsieur philippe hayat le fondateur en
2007 de l'association 100 1000
entrepreneurs une réflexion sur l'action
publique a mené dans notre pays pour
soutenir durablement l'esprit
d'entreprendre
je recevrai seule conclusion le 29 août
prochain faire sauter le plafond de
verre développer l'esprit d'entreprise
mais aussi gagner la bataille de
l'international mon troisième engagement
et je veux insister devant vous sur ce
point portera sur le soutien apporté aux
pme dans leur bataille pour la
compétitivité et la conquête des marchés
internationaux
le commerce extérieur de la france
traverse une passe très préoccupante en
un peu plus de dix ans la part des
exportations françaises dans l'est mais
échanges mondiaux a presque diminué de
moitié
alors comme vous le savez les pme sont
concernés au premier chef dans cette
tendance à la baisse
d'une part elles sont trop peu
nombreuses à exporter notamment par
rapport à aux entreprises allemandes ou
anglaises ou même italienne d'autre part
en valeur moins d'un euro sur deux
exporter provient des pme avec ma
collègue nicole bricq
nous mettrons donc en oeuvre pour faire
participer activement les pme à l'effort
de redressement nous mettrons tout en
oeuvre par don pour faire participer
activement les pme à l'effort de
redressement des exportations
on a beaucoup insisté au cours des
derniers mois et à juste titre sur le
différentiel de performance à
l'exportation qui s'est creusé au cours
des années 2000 entre la france et
l'allemagne à notre détriment
il est essentiel d'aider les pme à
renforcer la stratégie de
différenciation de leurs produits et de
leurs services à l'export
le prix ne fait pas tout et pour cela
j'entends soutenir de manière volontaire
la stratégie globale d'innovation des
entreprises dans ses différentes
dimensions accompagnement de la
transition numérique design marketing
stratégie de marque propriété
intellectuelle et c'est ce qui me permet
donc de faire une passerelle avec
l'innovation qui constitue effectivement
le second volet de mon portefeuille
je veux dire à moi à ce stade du nouveau
modèle français de l'innovation que nous
voulons bâtir avec arnaud montebourg
reste aux difficultés que connaît
actuellement le pays face à une
concurrence internationale acharné il
est plus que jamais nécessaire de se
tourner vers l'innovation pour tirer
parti des ressources considérables de
notre pays dans ce domaine il faut
d'abord changer la manière dont nous
pensons l'innovation sans doute faut-il
élargir nos approches pour ne pas la
réduire au seul grand programme de
recherche fondamentale
cette recherche publique cette recherche
fondamentale est indispensable c'est
pour tout dire un trésor national est
une locomotive
mais il nous faut construire une
stratégie d'ensemble au service de la
compétitivité économique de notre pays
qui ne se limiterait pas à cette
approche ou à une aide aux dépenses de
recherche et développement
tout d'abord les outils utiles et
structurants tels que le crédit impôt
recherche seront non seulement
pérenniser dans leur principe mais
seront même pleinement mobilisés le
crédit d'impôt recherche est un puissant
outil d aide à la recherche et
développement les entreprises comptent
sur lui pour développer leurs programmes
de recherche
il constitue un facteur majeur
d'attractivité pour les autres les
entreprises étrangères
nous devons donc protéger ce début de ce
dispositif crucial pour la compétitivité
long de long terme de la france françois
hollande a pris l'engagement
d'accompagner cette sanctuarisation
d'une double réforme
d'une part le rendre plus juste en le
recentrant sur les entreprises qui en
ont le plus besoin et d'autre part
essayer de l'ouvrir aux dépenses aval
d'innovation les pme concentre
effectivement aujourd'hui 22% du crédit
impôt recherche et sur les treize mille
bénéficiaires du crédit impôt recherche
les 21 plus gros capte plus d'un quart
du crédit total
ma conviction est que nous pouvons mieux
cibler les pme sans pour autant
pénaliser les grandes entreprises dont
le rôle est par ailleurs capitale pour
l'écosystème de l'innovation nationale
l'autre axe de réflexion de françois
hollande porte sur l'extension du crédit
impôt recherche aux dépenses
d'innovation le soutient la recherche
n'a de sens que si elle mène à la
commercialisation de produits innovants
qui en sont issus il faut donc
encourager des entreprises à valoriser
le fruit de la recherche
mais au delà du crédit impôt recherche
c'est bien un nouveau modèle
d'innovation qu'il nous faut construire
et il s'appuiera sur trois grands axes
le premier sera l'ancrage de
l'innovation dans les réalités des
territoires
plusieurs sur une ou plusieurs
structures de valorisation de transfert
et de soutien à la recherche et
développement ont été créés depuis
plusieurs années vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure monsieur le président incubateur
pôles de compétitivité technopole label
des instituts carnot sa critères dtr
terra jeudi à dessein les acronymes
parce qu'effectivement le paysage
aujourd'hui est devenu extrêmement
complexe je souhaite donc que l'on
veille à la bonne articulation entre ces
structures et à l'implication forte des
collectivités territoriales qui
connaissent leur pme et peuvent jouer un
rôle crucial dans c politique de
transferts les grands instituts de
recherche technologique
inria ca pour n'en citer que
quelques-uns auront aussi un grand rôle
d'impulsion à jouer
deuxièmement il faudra aussi agir sur le
financement de l'innovation l'objectif
étant de parvenir à mieux couvrir
l'ensemble de la chaîne de l'innovation
et de mieux concentrer les soutiens sur
les technologies clés et sur les
entreprises qui en ont le plus besoin en
particulier les pme innovantes
à cet égard je soutiendrai notamment le
maintien et le développement du
dispositif fiscal en faveur des jeunes
entreprises innovantes
je veillerai également à ce que la
banque publique d'investissement soit
organisé pour soutenir de manière très
efficace
l'innovation particulièrement au niveau
du capital risque et sur l'émission
hausse autrefois dévolues à l'envers
avant sa fusion avec oseo
le troisième axe de travail enfin
portera sur la valorisation et la
diffusion de la culture de l'innovation
l'objectif doit être de créer un choc
culturel aboutissant à la valorisation
de l'esprit d'innovation aux côtés de
l'esprit d'entreprise
une nouvelle culture de l'innovation
cela passe notamment dans mon esprit par
la promotion de l'étude du numérique à
l'école
je souhaite comme vincent peillon avancé
sur le développement dans notre pays du
manuel numérique mais aussi à la date
sur l'adaptation de l'offre pédagogique
et la valorisation des jeux vidéos
sérieux à but pédagogique et des
ressources pédagogiques en ligne une
nouvelle culture de l'innovation cela
implique aussi de réhabiliter la prise
de risques liés à l'investissement dans
les entreprises innovantes
celle ci sera encouragée tant pour les
particuliers que pour les grandes
entreprises
une nouvelle culture de l'innovation
exigent enfin la mise en place d'une
politique d'attractivité qui permettent
d'attirer des compétences et des
financements étrangers
c'est là toute nos tout mon ambition
faire de la france une terre d'accueil
reconnu des projets d'innovation
internationaux sur les télécoms et sur
le numérique
car je sais que votre commission est
particulièrement intéressés par ce sujet
avec dans ses rangs plusieurs
parlementaires a guéri je voudrais donc
vous dire un mot sur les secteurs des
télécoms et sur la politique numérique
un mot donc sur l'actualité brûlante du
secteur dans laquelle vous êtes plongés
depuis ce matin d'après ce que je
comprends et sur donc les difficultés
sur le front de l'emploi
nous avons rencontré avec arnaud
montebourg les quatre opérateurs de
téléphonie mobile afin d'identifier avec
eux les voies permettant de revenir vers
un modèle de croissance au bénéfice de
l'emploi et de l'investissement
j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire devant
l'assemblée nationale et je vous le dis
aussi aujourd'hui il n'est ni pensé ni
acceptable qu'un secteur comme celui des
télécoms qui est un secteur porteur de
croissance
réglementer protégés de la concurrence
internationale en tout cas dans son
coeur d'activité devienne un secteur
devienne un secteur destructeur
d'emplois c'est le message qu avec
arnaud montebourg nous avons adressé aux
représentants des salariés des
opérateurs que nous avons reçus la
semaine dernière c'est le même message
que nous adressons aux salariés des sous
traitants des opérateurs dans les
centres d'appels et les installateurs de
réseaux
l'autre message que nous défendons
depuis plusieurs semaines maintenant
c'est qu'il existe une voie permettant
de répondre à la fois aux attentes de
développement industriel des opérateurs
et garantissant les droits des
consommateurs à des services de bonne
qualité à des prix raisonnables
cette voix c'est celle de
l'investissement dans les relais de
croissance
ma conviction en matière de télécoms
c'est qu'il nous faut permettre que le
marché se développe en intégrant les
demandes des consommateurs et les
nouveaux besoins qui émergent
c'est de cette manière que l'on pourra à
nouveau créer de la valeur pour le
secteur et donc pour l'emploi et pour
l'investissement
nous ne jouons pas la division les
opérateurs contre les consommateurs sur
ce dossier comme sur d'autres notre
méthode demeure la concertation
concertation avec les syndicats
concertation avec les opérateurs
concertation avec les associations de
consommateurs mais aussi avec le conseil
national de le contrôle de la
consommation et le conseil stratégique
de filière services et technologies de
l'information et de la communication le
comique et le comité stick qui rattache
à la conférence nationale de l'industrie
en somme nous nous mobilisons et nous
continuerons à le faire pour empêcher
que des emplois soient détruits ou
délocalisés et nous souhaitons rappeler
notre détermination à ce que les
investissements nécessaires tant à
l'aménagement des territoires qu à la
compétitivité et à la croissance de
notre économie ne soit ni remis en cause
ni retardée permettez-moi donc pour en
finir d'ajouter un mot sur le très haut
débit fixe et le déploiement de la fibre
optique
la situation est difficile et parfois
critique dans certains territoires
je le dis sans ambages nous ne sommes
pas au niveau de la tempe des français
puisque aujourd'hui près de 50 % d'entre
eux n'ont pas accès à un internet haut
débit satisfaisant leur permettant
d'avoir accès à une offre triple play de
qualité il s'agit souvent des zones
périurbaines ou rurales
je comprends le mécontentement des
personnes qui sont situées dans ces
zones qui sont de plus en plus souvent
gêné par la lenteur du débit que ce soit
dans leur pratique personnelle ou
professionnelle manque de concertation
entre élus et opérateurs manque de
visibilité sur les objectifs à atteindre
manque de financement nous considérons
que le programme national
au débit a créé aujourd'hui beaucoup de
frustration le président de la
république alors candidat s'était engagé
à couvrir l'intégralité du territoire en
très haut débit en dix ans pour réaliser
cet objectif et pour agir efficacement
j'entends changer de logique en
partageant des besoins de nos
concitoyens et de nos territoires
en partant pardon en partant des besoins
de nos têtes de nos concitoyens et de
nos territoires
d'abord il nous faut clarifier les
objectifs de couverture
compte tenu des disparités territoriales
sans doute faudra-t-il réfléchir en
parallèle du déploiement du très haut
débit à un objectif devrait haut débit
pour tous dès la fin du quinquennat
ensuite sur une clarification du rôle
respectif de l'état des opérateurs et
des collectivités locales l'état devra
sans doute préciser le cadre
d'investissement des opérateurs et des
collectivités locales et sécurisé chaque
acteur dans ses projets d'investissement
il n'est pas tolérable que des élus qui
n'est que les élus n'est pas d'assurance
sur l'utilisation qui sera faite de
leurs réseaux par les opérateurs
dans le même temps ceux ci doivent
disposer également d'un cadre
d'intervention clair pour libérer
l'investissement
enfin la question du financement doit
être tranchée nous nous mobiliserons
pour que l'europe prenne sa part dans
l'effort de financement public mais
l'état jouera pleinement son rôle de
garant de la compétitivité de notre pays
et de la solidarité entre les
territoires
je pense donc naturellement aux
mécanismes de péréquation que l'état
devra mettre en place pour assurer le
financement des projets situés dans les
zones où les prix ou le déploiement du
très haut débit présente des
caractéristiques économiques moins
rentable que dans les zones denses en
lien avec arnaud montebourg et en
associant cécile duflot je présenterai
donc à la rentrée une feuille de route
précise sur ce sujet qui sera ici d'un
processus de concertation qui commence
dès ce vendredi concernant le
déploiement de la 4g
nous souhaitons également que ses
services se déploie le plus rapidement
possible deux bandes de fréquences sont
aujourd'hui accessibles mais vous le
savez les travaux complémentaires
doivent être menées sur les fréquences
issues du dividende numérique pour
éviter les brouillage de la tnt
la question de l'utilisation de la bande
1800 mhz hier s'est également posé la
volonté du gouvernement sur ce point et
d'avancer vite parce que les attentes de
nos concitoyens sont très fortes
il nous faut lever l'ensemble des
contraintes qui pourraient exister au
lancement de ce nouveau service mobile
au bénéfice de l'emploi et de
l'aménagement du territoire la volonté
du gouvernement et lancer une nouvelle
impulsion
en matière de diffusion du numérique
dans la société c'est d'un côté d'un
côté toucher les populations fragiles et
de l'autre avancée sur l'administration
numérique ou l'e-administration en effet
deux grands axes de travail sur cette
question de l'économie numérique celui
tout d'abord d'une meilleure diffusion
du numérique au sein des territoires et
de l'économie française pour les plus
petites entreprises et auprès des
personnes les plus fragiles et celui en
suite de la diffusion du numérique au
sein des administrations de l'état comme
de celles des collectivités locales
c'est gentil relève évidemment d'une
logique interministériel sous l'autorité
du premier ministre je serai celle qui
portera la volonté du gouvernement sur
ces chantiers pme innovation télécom
très haut débit numérique
mes sujets sont en quelque sorte ce qui
dessine l'avenir de la france et donc
souhaité dans son propos liminaire vous
communiquer mes premières pistes de
réflexion et de travail en même temps
que l'enthousiasmé qui m'anime dans
cette belle mission qui m'est confiée
merci beaucoup alors nous allons engager
donc les questions michel teston le
premier merci messieurs
ah pardon d'entrée je jouerai si
beaucoup je voulais juste si vous me
permettez monsieur est présent la
ministre a rappelé à la ministre
quand même le travail qui a été accompli
par le sénat au cours des derniers mois
puisque il y a tout juste un an nous
avons adopté à l'unanimité de la
commission de l'économie du
développement durable et de
l'aménagement du territoire commission
qui ne faisait qu'une à l'époque un
rapport qui s'appelait passer de la
parole aux actes et qui je crois dont le
titre a le mérite d'être clair dans le
prolongement de ceux de ce rapport nous
avons co signé avec mon collègue
philippe leroy une proposition de loi
qui a été adopté à une très large
majorité au mois de février dernier
et dans cette proposition de loi il y a
trois volets sur lesquels je voudrais
revenir quelques instants
premier sujet le haut débit parce qu'on
parle beaucoup de très haut débit mais
il y a encore des territoires qui n'ont
même pas de haut débit et quand vous
parlez de l'offre triple play il ya des
territoires qui se contenterait encore
de 512 kilobits seconde ou de 2 mégas et
on sait que sur le 2 méga il y a
que 77 % de la population qui ont ce
cette couverture minimale deuxième et
donc dans une proposition de loi on
avait suggéré qu'il y ait un véritable
droit haut débit pour tous qui soit
reconnue on avait renvoyé à l'arcep le
soin de fixer les modalités soient en
incluant cinq ans de service universel
comme c'est possible soit en en faisant
un droit opposable
deuxième sujet c'est celui de la
téléphonie mobile dont vous n'avez pas
parlé madame la ministre nous demandons
depuis longtemps à ce que l'on revoit la
manière dont on appréhende le taux de
couverture puisque aujourd'hui on a des
taux de couverture très flatteur parce
que on mesure uniquement à l'extérieur
en zone en zone habitée est en position
immobile et donc votre prédécesseur a
créé un groupe de travail qui n'a
vraiment servi à rien puisque il ajuste
pondu quelques recommandations du qui
sont un ensemble de poncifs et de
platitudes absolument affligeant et donc
je crois qu'il faudrait reprendre le
travail sur ce sujet là et troisième
sujet vous en avait parlé
c'est la question du très haut débit
nous considérons pour la plupart d'entre
nous ici que le programme national très
haut débit fait la part beaucoup trop
belle aux opérateurs puisque aujourd'hui
tout le déploiement repose uniquement
sur le bon vouloir des opérateurs qui
vont là où il vole là où il vole quand
ils volent au rythme qu'il souhaite et
qu'ils ne sont absolument pas liés par
ce par leur effet d'annonce qui en
revanche qui en revanche a des
conséquences sur les collectivités
puisque vous le savez dès lors que
l'opérateur dit qu'il couvrira une zone
la collectivité ne peut plus y aller au
risque de perdre toute subvention y
compris sur la zone non denses donc dans
cette proposition de loi on avait
souhaité non pas remettre en cause le
modèle 2d de déploiement choisi m'est
arrivé un rééquilibrage entre les
opérateurs et les collectivités
reposant sur une contractualisation
entre collectivités opérateurs
contractualisation contrôle et
éventuellement sanctionner en cas de non
respect par l'arcep
on avait souhaité mais on n'a pas pu
trancher cette question aussi que soit
enfin alimenter le fonds d'aménagement
numérique du territoire et que l'on
reconnaisse aux collectivités qui le
souhaitent la possibilité de couvrir
l'ensemble de
leur territoire dans un souci de
péréquation alors ma question comme ça
je pense que je ne dépasserait pas 5
minutes que le président m'a accordé
dans son immense mansuétude
ma question c'est que comptez vous faire
que madame la ministre que le
gouvernement compte-t-il faire de cette
proposition de loi je ne vous ai pas
entendu en parler c'est quand il ya un
travail qui a été fourni par le sénat
dans sa globalité il je ne prétends pas
qu'elle soit à la c'est qu'elles ne
soient pas modifiées à qu'elle ne soit
pas un mandat qu'elle ne soit pas
améliorable mais je pense que ce serait
important qu'elle soit inscrite à
l'ordre du jour de l'assemblée nationale
parce que sur un sujet aussi important
avoir un texte législatif c'est quand
même quelque chose de politiquement fort
et ça permettrait quand même d'avoir un
cadre bien précis pour pour l'ensemble
des acteurs
vous avez rappelé que le présent la
république avait fixé un objectif
ambitieux encore plus ambitieux que ceux
de son prédécesseur
ils ont lequel j'avais déjà des doutes
quant au fait qu'on le l'atteignent donc
j'ai eu l'occasion de vous le dire si on
veut que l'objectif du président
république soient tenus il faut vraiment
changer de braquet et pour l'instant
mais vous n'êtes là que depuis deux mois
je ne sens pas encore ce changement de
braquet et je vous redis publiquement ce
que j'ai eu l'occasion de vous dire je
ne suis pas dans la majorité mais je
soutiendrai toutes les actions qui vont
dans le bon sens en ce domaine parce que
je crois que l'aménagement numérique des
territoires c'est un sujet qui doit
faire consensus
parce que les enjeux sont trop
importants en termes économiques en
terme d'aménagement du territoire et
aussi sur un sujet dont on à nous-mêmes
insuffisamment parler en terme de deux
filières industrielles
parce qu'il ya une filière une filière
une filière nationale
l'importante et créatrice d'emplois et
je crois qu'il faut absolument faire en
sorte de l'encourager donc pour conclure
je dirai simplement que je souhaite que
le slogan selon lequel le changement
c'est maintenant s'applique pleinement
en matière de numérique
merci monsieur hervé m'aurait alors
maintenant michel teston merci messieurs
merci mais le fun c'est une adhésion
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre merci d'avoir décrit les
principales orientations de notre action
j'interviendrai seulement sur le très
haut débit fixe et ce en deux temps
premier temps je dirais quelques mots
sur le plan national très haut débit qui
organise à mon sens un déploiement
numérique à deux vitesses et ensuite je
formulerai trois suggestions principal
pour éviter justement une france
numérique à deux vitesses en avance sur
le plan national très haut débit
je reprendrai une partie de l'analyse
qui a été faite par hervé maurey puisque
nous sommes en phase sur ce qu'il faut
penser de ce plan national très haut
débit
il favorise effectivement trop les
opérateurs et ils cantonnent les
collectivités territoriales dans le
déploiement de réseaux dans les zones
très peu denses et il a d'autres
inconvénients c'est que comme cela a été
dit aussi par hervé il gèle les
initiatives des collectivités
territoriales dans la mesure où un
opérateur dit s'engager et en plus s'il
ne s'engage pas réellement plan national
très haut débit ne prévoit actuellement
aucune sanction à l'encontre de
l'opérateur qui en quelque sorte à geler
les initiatives des collectivités
territoriales et puis dernier point si
une collectivité à un projet intégré qui
porte à la fois sur une zones
moyennement denses et nous sommes très
peu dense et bien
l'interprétation qui en a été fait je
parle du plan national très haut débit
par le gouvernement fillon fait que ces
collectivités ne peuvent pas être aidé
cette collectivité ne pas être aidé pour
la partie très peu dense et puis alors
le dernier point c'est que le fonds
d'aménagement numérique du territoire
qu'on a créé avec la loi pintât
il ya déjà deux ans ou trois ans n'a
jamais été alimentées donc voilà pour le
constat que l'on peut faire sur le plan
national de lille et suggestions à
grands traits trois principales pour
éviter une france numérique 1 à deux
vitesses d'abord contractualiser
l'engagement des opérateurs et permettre
à l'autorité de régulation des
communications électroniques et des
postes de poux
à sanctionner le non respect des
engagements deuxième suggestion
permettre aux collectivités qui
investissent dans des projets intégrés
pourtant la fois sur les zones
moyennement denses est très peu dense
d'être aidés dans les zones très peu
denses ce que ne prévoit pas
actuellement le plan national
et puis troisièmement abonder le fonds
d'aménagement numérique du territoire
notamment en faisant en sorte que les
opérateurs participent
ce serait donc une véritable péréquation
au fur et à mesure qu'ils développeront
leurs réseaux dans les zones très denses
et moyennement denses en quelque sorte
on leur demandera de consacrer une
partie de leurs recettes à la
péréquation nationale pour aider
notamment les collectivités à développer
des réseaux dans les zones les moins
denses ce qui serait à mon avis la
moindre des choses
on trouvera ainsi probablement un moyen
de faire évoluer le plan national très
haut débit de manière satisfaisante et
d'avancer plus rapidement dans le
respect peut-être dans ce cas des
engagements pris par le président de la
république c'est à dire sous dix ans de
couvrir en grande partie en très grande
partie le territoire national
merci donc la parole est à mme naïve
rome oui monsieur le président madame la
ministre
un sujet important sur lequel bien
entendu l'intérêt de bon nombre de
collectivités est très grand
l'inquiétude également tous les constats
qui sont dressés aujourd'hui sur le plan
du plan très haut débit tels que le
précédent président de la république
l'avait défini pour une atteinte de
l'objectif 1 15 ans ne fonctionne pas le
rapport de notre collègue hervé morin a
témoigné ô combien efficacement à
l'examen de la proposition de loi que
nous avons travaillé au sénat un a
également apporté la preuve
supplémentaire les chiffres mêmes de
l'arcep témoin une très concrètement que
sur la base des prises
bise à très haut débit il faudrait quasi
80 ans dans le rythme actuel pour
atteindre l'objectif de la même manière
les siècles qui regroupe les syndicats
des entreprises intéressées l objectif
témoigne là aussi de l'insuffisance du
plan et du routard que l'état nation est
en train de prendre sur le sujet
relevant bien sûr une grande inquiétude
sur l'emploi et sur la capacité
d'innovation et d'apport à la croissance
que tout le monde l'espère de ses voeux
et qui ne se réalise pas donc le plan
très haut débit ne fonctionne pas on
peut se féliciter comme viennent de le
faire d'ailleurs à sa conclusion notre
collègue hervé maurey que le président
de la république actuel est fixé
l'objectif à 10 ans car sur des sujets
d'importance pour la croissance pour
l'emploi pour une rénovation du bien
vivre ensemble sur les territoires nous
avons là un outil fabuleux et il faut
savoir se fixer des frontières
indépassable pour que dans le cadre du
new deal du numérique nous puissions
briser le plafond de verre pour
reprendre l'expression vous avez utilisé
ce constat il est partagé il est unanime
en fait comment peut-on demander
à des opérateurs que l'on stigmatise
parfois à juste titre mais pas toujours
d'atteindre l'objectif qui est celui
fixé par le président la république tout
en sachant il faut mobiliser 25 à 30 il
y as d'euros soit une moyenne de 2
milliards et demi à 3 milliards d'euros
par an le principal opérateur mobilisent
sur le sujet chez des chiffres qui vont
été communiqué pas plus tard que hier
midi par le secrétaire général 300
millions d'euros c'est à dire sur la
capacité d'investissement de l'opérateur
historique
c'est plus 80 ans qu'il faudrait c'est
quasiment un siècle
donc il est donc important que sur le
sujet sans vouloir tout révolutionner
immédiatement le gouvernement puisque
vous êtes porteuse de 7h lourdes
ambitions puisse nous dire très
rapidement quels correctifs apportés au
plan national très haut débit qui ne
fonctionne pas et très rapidement pour
le court terme et le moyen terme vous
indiquer quel changement de paradigme
pour que les objectifs fixés par le
président de la république puisse
connaître une crédibilité certaine sur
l'ensemble du territoire national
il s'agira pas d'opposer tel opérateur à
tel autre opérateur
il s'agira pas d'opposer les opérateurs
aux collectivités territoriales il
s'agira de mobiliser toutes les
intelligences collectives sur l'atteinte
de l'objectif en tout cas nous gardons
les uns et les autres bien que ce plan
soit presque un parfait mais il a été
vérifié par l'ensemble des observateurs
du sujet que sur le haut débit la france
avait réussi à être parmi les leaders
mondiaux en tout cas les lieder sur le
théâtre européen seul avait pu être
réalisée dans l'heureux mariage ou dans
l'heureuse coopération entre les
opérateurs et les collectivités
territoriales
il est donc important
que ce qui avait fonctionné pour le haut
débit puis cette mise à neuf sur le très
haut débit à la condition bien entendu
que l'état que vous représentez ici
puissent devenir le vrai pilote de ce
grand sujet de compétition
internationale merci alors je suis bruno
retailleau
je suis toujours étonné quand on indique
que programme très haut débit ne
fonctionne pas alors qu'il vient de
démarrer que les collectivités j'en fait
partie d'ailleurs qui ont été admises
commence tout juste à comment dirais-je
à déployer comment peut-on porter un
jugement aussi brutale à avant même que
les opérations soient commencer je
voudrais poser deux groupes de questions
brême ministre je pense que le très haut
débit
ces deux infrastructures essentielles
qui sont complémentaires mobiles et
fixes
la première sur la 4g c'est important à
plus d'un titre
y compris économique s'intéresse aussi à
notre commission c'est nous avons veillé
à ce que les conditions d'attribution
des fréquences fasse que pour la
première fois de l'histoire des télécoms
en france les opérateurs soit obligé de
déployer simultanément les antennes dans
les villes et dans la zone prioritaire
rural bien sous prétexte que je
comprends les opérateurs déploient de
façon expérimentale aujourd'hui dans les
villes
ma question est comment comptez vous
madame ministre faire respecter
l'obligation réglementaire conventionnel
que les opérateurs ont pris de déployer
simultanément dans les villes et dans la
zone prioritaire pour la 4g c'est
important pour le milieu rural
la deuxième question concerne le fameux
programme thd qui doit être bien sûr
amélioré trois questions très précises
merci d'y apporter les réponses très
précises parce que les inquiétudes se
portent effectivement sur trois points
particuliers
premier point sur l'engagement des
opérateurs comment comptez vous les
faire respecter est ce que vous êtes
favorable à une sanction financière
vis-à-vis des opérateurs ou est-ce que
vous êtes favorable à un autre
dispositif
première question
l'autre point concerne la
complémentarité où la concurrence entre
l'initiative publique et l'initiative
privée
on peut faire beaucoup discours le point
essentiel me semble-t-il est la question
que je pose est la suivante êtes vous
prête demain à subventionner des
initiatives publiques dans les zones
amis
troisième point sur le financement nous
sommes tous d'accord pour dire
qu'aujourd'hui sur le le programme
national ya un sou subventionnement des
projets moi je pense que le guichet à
les opérateurs on ont très peu besoin
je pense que les collectivités qui
peinent à avoir des financements sur
auprès des banques pourrait trouver là
des financements intéressants ont
préféré des subventions mais bon s'ils
sont des prêts à un taux réduit
je pense qu'il faut dans la période
actuelle être raisonnable sur le guichet
à sur l'europe je pense alors la
commissaire avait annoncé un certain
nombre de milliards pour les
infrastructures mais elle avait séparé
en même temps une part pour le numérique
aujourd'hui on parle d project bond
ça me semblerait inconcevable que les
projets xv bond se fasse sans une
dimension européenne et numérique
quel est votre avis est toujours sur le
financement troisième point sur
l'alimentation du fan la taxe nous
l'avions indiqué d'ailleurs au moment où
la suppression de la publicité sur la
sur france télévisions a été voté la
taxe sur les opérateurs n'est pas
eurocompatible la question est par
exemple est-ce que alors elle serait pas
plus compatibles sont là vers celle en
femme et elle peut l'être
on pourra en parler en dehors on peut
s'arranger pour qu'elle le soit
néanmoins bien avec un acheminement jury
très précis est ce que vous seriez est
ce que le fan par exemple pourraient
être financées par ce biais là puisque
cette taxe la la destination de cette
taxe va tomber elle n'est pas euro
compatibles et je pense que ce serait
vertueux que les opérateurs puissent
financer des réseaux qui en même temps
font progresser leur chiffre d'affaires
et je pense dernier point qui est
important c'est que le bleu on a tous
souffert du fait et les collectivités
notamment
eux qui est pas de pilotage national la
question de l'argent est une question
mais sur un chantier aussi stratégique
je pense que l'état doit rester stratège
doit avoir une task force je le dis que
j'avais fait un rapport d'ailleurs y
aille dans 2007 sur les dix ans de la
recette je l'avais déjà indiqué il faut
constituer madame il vous faut une task
force auprès de vous plutôt
interministériel mais il vous la faux
parce que sinon l'etat sera réduit à
quelques subventions plus en plus rares
et aux mystères de la parole merci merci
jean luc fichet vous voulez monsieur le
président madame la ministre
tout d'abord je voudrais rappeler une
chose c'est que quand on aborde la
question du très haut débit
on a toujours le sentiment qu'il faut
alimenter très vite les grandes unités
les grosses entreprises ce sont elles
qui ont besoin et dans les faits on
constate que dans nos milieux ruraux on
a aussi des entreprises qui sont des
studios d'enregistrement par exemple
notre tout prix ce qui travaillent sur
l'image qui elles ont besoin de très
haut débit et pas forcément les grosses
entreprises
on ne travaille aujourd'hui sur la
question des déserts médicaux et et donc
on a comme premier élément de réponse
sera comme approche
la télémédecine et si on devait
effectivement développer cet aspect là
ça veut dire qu'il y à aussi une
nécessité impérieuse d'avoir du très
haut débit
mais au moment où on parle de
financement moi j'aimerais m'arrêter sur
une question qui est qui paraître un peu
secondaire mais qui comme une chose
économie et qui entre les cases source
d'incompréhension de la part des des
élus locaux à savoir les les
infrastructures qui existent aujourd'hui
ça qu'on sait que france télécom
aujourd'hui à chaque fois qu'ils
réalisent du génie civil
il pose des fourreaux en parallèle de ce
qui lui est nécessaire
circle il anticipe sur le besoin de
déroulement de la fibre optique et se
réserve le moment venu la possibilité de
déroulé très vite de la fibre optique
cependant il garde sa très confidentiel
ce qui fait qu on a des collectivités
qui aujourd'hui réalise des travaux de
génie civil
en parallèle de ce qui existe déjà par
france télécom et je pense qu'ils sont
arrivés à trouver un accord avec france
télécom pour qu'ils soient plus
engageant dans ce domaine et qu'il nous
dit
où sont ces réservations on pourrait
déjà généré des économies qui sont
importantes
je crois qu'il ya une loi qui le dit
mais pour l'instant c'est cette loi ne
s'applique pas des fautes décrets
d'application sans doute d'oka il ya des
avancées à faire sur cette question là
et donc je souhaiterais bien évidemment
savoir un peu comment vous pensez
approché l'opérateur en question pour
que l'on puisse régler cette question et
puis mais faire en sorte qu'on ne soit
pas obligé de dépenser l'argent public
qui se fait rare par les temps qui
courent merci merci n'a pas envie d'en
alain fouché
messieurs les présidents vous avez
souhaité que les questions soient
courtes donc je serai cours de simples
questions
madame la ministre vous favorable aux
propositions de martin bouygues visant à
limiter le recours aux accords
d'itinérance pour déployer le mobile 3g
et 4g une question si je crois a été
évoqué c'est quelle piste voyez-vous
pour l'abondement du fonds d'aménagement
numérique du territoire
je crois que c'est très important je
suis pas plus non
merci mon petit monsieur martial
bourquin l'âme ministre mais l'ensemble
de mes collègues ont attiré l'attention
sur le plan national haut débit il
s'agit à la fois de l'égalité des
citoyens sur des infrastructures
absolument nécessaire mais il s'agit
j'entends beaucoup aujourd'hui j'écoute
les réactions aux plantes mobile on
parle de compétitivité de notre
industrie
ça fait partie de la compétitivité de
nos territoires et de l'industrie est un
sujet j'aurai beaucoup les deux
questions on parle beaucoup des
initiations et que ce soit dans les
entreprises à dominante numérique comme
dans les autres pme la question on sait
très bien que la désindustrialisation
vient essentiellement du sort qui est
réservé aux pv dans ce pays est depuis
des décennies et il ya un rapport qui
est sorti trois semaines dans challenges
de monsieur vau l'eau qui parle de ces
pme qu'on assassine
je partage complètement le constat qui a
fait qu'est ce qui est fait pour essayer
de rééquilibrer les relations entre les
grands donneurs d'ordre et nos pme
deuxième chose que sûr il ya eu un
rapport du groupement des entreprises
informatiques
il y a eu le conseil
économique et social non c'est pas pour
ça
le conseil économique et social et
l'igas qui ont fait un rapport sur les
entreprises informatiques et le recours
abusif à la sous-traitance et alex
tergnier l'externalisation croissante
des directions informatiques
oui non si si c'est lié quand même c'est
lié quand même on est en plein dans le
sujet il ya une politique de réduction
des coûts massives qui se fait dans ces
entreprises et la loi de 75 est
systématiquement détournées notamment
l'article 1 et 3 il faut que nous
arrivions à concernant la sous traitance
dans ces entreprises comme dans
l'ensemble de la sous traitance à avoir
des rapports beaucoup plus équilibrée
entre les grands donneurs d'ordre et les
sous-traitants
que pensez vous que pensez-vous faire
concernant ce rééquilibrage entre les
sous traitants et les grands donneurs
d'ordre dans cette branche là mais aussi
dans l'ensemble des branches
industrielles
merci là pour le thème en lançant si oui
mais
je vais m'inscrire dans la continuité de
mon collègue martial bourquin parce que
la mise d'abord pour vous féliciter de
votre nomination c'est la fois rock vous
venez dans notre commission donc c'est
le moment de le faire revenir le plaisir
que nous avons à vous accueillir
et puis aussi parce que au scénar vous
allez voir vous allez être beaucoup
ministre de du numérique beaucoup mais
est effectivement martial bourquin a
raison de parler des pme parce que nous
avons effectivement un tissu de pme
extrêmement fragile à la fois pour ceux
que celles qui sont déjà existantes mais
aussi pour les restos pour les nouvelles
pour les start up et j'ai eu l'occasion
de rencontrer récemment votre cabinet
mais avec un un dossier qui était je
baille demande aussi avait parce qu'il
est assez assez exemplaire est assez
banal somme toute d'une entreprise d'une
jeune entreprise très sérieuse et très
performante sur le plan de l'innovation
et qui ne trouvent dans un premier temps
pas de fonds d'amorçage et puis dans un
deuxième temps pas de fond de croissance
c'est à dire que quand ces gens vous
disent au bout d'un moment d'écouté
voilà qu'est ce qu'on soit on part aux
états unis parce que les fonds là bas on
les trouve on les levées de fonds sont
rapides et efficaces
soit nous on veut rester en france mais
comment on fait la banque publique
d'investissement est une est une réponse
elle est très attendue
très attendu jeu razer quelqu'un driller
sur la bombe puis d'investissement puis
après je pose une question un peu un
probablement un peu naïve une question
c'est daniel raoul qui fait du buzz fait
du buzz tout fort que je profite j'aime
pas quand tu sais c'est bien monsieur le
président que j'aime pas quand je veux
pas profiter de vos bons mots quand vous
lui réservez vos voisines et je compte
je continue donc
question naïve comment se fait-il qu'on
ait aucun moyen à l'égard des banques
françaises qui ont une capacité de
risques incommensurables quand il s'agit
d'intervenir dans le secteur financier
et un refus du risque total lorsqu'il
s'agit d'intervenir dans le secteur des
pme
voilà et jeu
je me demande quand même pourquoi on n'a
pas les outils de contraintes de
négociation de discussions avec les
banques pour les conduire si ce n'est
par des formes légales au moins par deux
la discussion a réorienté leurs
interventions et à prendre un tout petit
peu de risque et qui souvent sont à
risque d'ailleurs très mesuré ou parce
qu'on est capable avec l identifier des
entreprises qui à coup sûr vont réussir
pour peu qu'on ait les moyens de les
garder en france
alors les questions de monsieur jean
claude lenoir et 4 et une mondaine
desailly ont-elles trait au numérique
voilà non c'est parce qu'avant qu'avant
que vous arriviez nous avions défini que
les premières questions avaient trait et
vous étiez là et l'europe n'était pas là
donc c'est pour ça que le président raul
tout sahraouis baptisé cher papa râler
mais là il a parlé aussi si peu si peu
alors monsieur le noir et madame bon une
saillie vous intervenez à nos cadres du
numérique une fraise c'est monsieur
raoul qui prend la suite pour les
questions qui ont trait tout le reste
oui mais messieurs les présidents
messieurs les présidents madame la
ministre
les excellentes interventions de mais
non moins excellent collègue qui m'ont
précédé randy dutil une bonne partie du
propos durs et tonus qui va satisfaire
le président raúl a reviré simplement
vous poser deux questions madame le
ministre à bord est ce que vous serez
possible de nous faire un état
comparatif de la situation du haut débit
et du très haut débit en france et en
europe que nous voyons puisque tout à
l'heure de vous parler de la compétition
compétitivité qu'en est il chez nos
voisins
deuxième question j'ai été extrêmement
intéressé doit entendre parler du
contenu des moyens qu'ils ont offerts
notamment aux jeunes à travers le
numérique les outils pédagogiques
on parle beaucoup de technique mais il
est important et l'initiative que vous
avez pris je crois en prenant contact
avec votre collègue vincent peillon me
paraît extrêmement intéressante
aujourd'hui on s'aperçoit que les jeunes
ont des facilités que nous n'avions pas
en tout cas je parle pour les personnes
de ma génération je parle pour les
jeunes de ma gêne les personnes de ma
génération est en réalité en aperçoit on
s'aperçoit que malgré les technologies
qui leur sont offertes le contenu qui
pourrait leur servir pour leur formation
leurs informations leur éducation
c'est complètement inexistant puisque en
réalité c'est un contenu plutôt ludique
alors je serais intéressé à savoir
quelles sont les pistes que vous avez
par rapport à ça je me permets tellement
nous préciser que étant revenus à une
réunion de commission de contrôle
l'application des lois à 16 heures il
est possible qu'au moment où vous
pourriez à paroles je ne sois pas là
sachez simplement que je pourrai
malheureusement pas dépasser 16 heures
en tout cas c'est pas pour vous demander
de vous répondre en premier
simplement pour éviter que vous puissiez
penser que je ne manifestaient pas la
politesse élémentaire
si madame morin desailly oui tout à leur
collègue hervé maurey a souligné
l'importance de l'aménagement du
territoire parce que il a dit que
c'était un enjeu économique je dois
aller plus loin et dire c'est un enjeu
sociétal un enjeu de santé comme vous
l'avez rappelé d'ailleurs très justement
dans la liste ia au club parlementaire
du numérique un enjeu de civilisation
une rue éducatif moi je crois qu'on est
plus sur internet je crois qu'on est
dans internet et je renvoie du cher
collègue aux conclusions du colloque que
d'un groupe médias et nouvelles
technologies organisé la semaine
dernière parce que c'était sur les
effets sociétaux de la révolution
numérique et on a mesuré la à la faveur
d'intervenants extrêmement brillant le
monde dans lequel nous nous basculions
moi je m'intéresse plutôt aux usages
madame la ministre est notre
préoccupation est aussi dans cette
enceinte plus largement de de savoir
comment parce que finalement je pense
que ça va ce traité aux nouveaux repères
comment on va lutter contre les géants
américains je crois que c'est une
stratégie globale et industriels du
numérique il nous faut soutenir et ce au
niveau européen dans une europe plus en
plus intégrés financièrement
budgétairement fiscalement
notre commission des affaires
européennes quand elle s'est rendue à la
cosaque à copenhague je parle sous le
contrôle de ma collègue bernadette
bourzai en avril dernier a vraiment
souligner je voulais d'hier à quel point
il était important que la fiscalité ne
puisse pas faire l'objet d'une
concurrence déloyale entre pays qui
pratiquent le dumping fiscal et 6
salle du coût des géants américains qui
aime capter toute la valeur ajoutée de
ce que nous savons intelligemment
construire en tout cas dans notre pays
il ya là une vraie question qui nous
préoccupe
nous allons la poursuite des travaux du
gouvernement actuel quant à la défense
aussi d'une tva adapté aux oeuvres
numériques je pense en particulier aux
livres numériques vous savez que c'est
le sénat qui a été fer de lance de cette
tva adapté et harmoniser avec le support
papier mais également la presse nous
avons aussi fait passer un amendement
ici qui harmonise la presse numérique à
la presse papier
la presse est justement un monde qui est
bouge beaucoup et qui subit de plein
fouet la mutation numérique ce sont des
entreprises plus ou moins grandes qui
ont aussi besoin de se voir définir de
nouvelles modèles économiques je voulais
un petit peu savoir aussi sur ce sujet
particulier ce que vous en pensiez mais
avant tout comment vous plaidez vous
même et vous engager au profit d'une
stratégie européenne globalisant
c'est-à-dire qu'ils intègrent également
la fabrication des équipements des
logiciels d'application des
serveur à quand un info nuage européen
je pense qu'un danger aussi civilisation
de captation des données et il ya une
peut-être une question essentielle
google prétendez vouloir organiser
l'information du monde est ce que c'est
ce que nous souhaitons très clairement
la question mon hambourg zé voilà merci
monsieur le président je ne reviendrai
pas sur les aspects techniques du haut
débit puisque ils ont été abondamment
développée par michel teston qui est un
maître en la matière et mes collègues
j'insiste simplement sur le fait qu'il
est important pour les collectivités
territoriales qui ont pris des
initiatives au niveau du haut débit je
pense en particulier à la région
limousin avec le syndicat mixte dorsal
qu'il est important
effectivement de soutenir ces
collectivités territoriales pour
qu'elles puissent couvrir l'ensemble des
territoires ruraux y compris handicapées
qu'il s'agisse de haute de moyenne
montagne ou d'isolement comme les îles
ma question madame la ministre portera
principalement sur les financements
européens
la commission des affaires européennes
et la commission économique du sénat ont
adopté cette ut en février une ppr sur
le mécanisme d'interconnexion pour
l'europe qui portait sur 50 milliards de
crédits dont 30 milliards de mémoire
pour les transports 10 milliards pour
les interconnexions énergétiques et
environ 10 milliards un petit peu moins
pour le
tout l'été communication j'aimerais
savoir madame la ministre si ces 50
milliards sont bien prévues dans le plan
de relance qui vient d'être adoptée au
dernier conseil européen
et quelle part quels usages de la france
espère faire de ces crédits pour
justement répondre aux besoins de lancer
ou de relancer ce schéma national du
haut débit
merci au ministre
alors du coup je vais prendre en ordre
où je joue sur plusieurs mois il ya en
fait ya pas mal de questions c'est vrai
qu'ils se qui se recoupent dont je vais
peut-être faire plaisir à monsieur le
noir parce que comme une non ça va pas
je suis le flac une avalanche allait
rapidement / / / lit sur l'éducation
parce qu'effectivement les usagers
madame morin dessailly on a parlé aussi
je pense que c'est quand même aussi à un
aspect qu'on a assez peu et flore et
jusqu'à présent les tuyaux c'est
important mais effectivement les usages
c'est très important pour rentabiliser
ces fameux tuyaux donc je pense
qu'effectivement nous avons porté
pendant la campagne des projets très
ambitieux
qui mettront sans doute un certain temps
pour voir le jour mais effectivement je
pense qu'il ya des applications
absolument et des usages absolument
indispensable qu'il nous faut développer
en matière d'éducation et de numérique
parce que tout d'abord parce que les
autres pays commencent à prendre
énormément d'avant sur ces sujets et par
conséquent deviennent un peu leader sur
tout ce qui est standard des
standardisations énorme et on sait bien
qu'en matière numérique quand on quand
on possède la capacité déterminer les
standards et les normes et ben on est
des maîtres du monde et donc les
français sont un peu en retard là dessus
et c'est vrai aussi en matière
d'éducation
aujourd'hui les éditeurs de livres
scolaires sont en train de prendre la
mesure de la transit de la nécessité de
la transition numérique donc on
travaille avec eux pour pour pour pour
alléger le cartable mais aussi pour
réfléchir et là c'est important de
mettre l'enseignant au coeur de cette
réflexion réfléchir à la manière dont le
numérique peut modifier en profondeur la
pédagogie et ça je pense que c'est
extrêmement important parce que tous les
pays dans lesquels ces réformes sont
réussis sont des pays qui se sont
construites autour - de l'élève que de
l'enseignant pour poste pour que la
réforme soit plus acceptable et aussi
parce que il ya nécessairement il s'agit
pas uniquement de donner des supports
des tablettes ou des ordinateurs mais il
faut vraiment réfléchir au contenu
je crois que c'est ça qui est très
important c'est de redéfinir la manière
dont le numérique peut favoriser le
travail collaboratif à ça change
complètement les pratiques pédagogiques
donc ça je crois que c'est très
important et c'est un chantier sur
lequel travaille actuellement françois
momboisse 1 dans le cadre du chantier
qui a été lancé par par vincent peillon
et nous nous avons une réflexion
parallèlement sur la manière dont nous
pourrions modifier effectivement les
maquettes pédagogiques à la fois dans le
secondaire nous aussi dans le supérieur
pour les orienter sur l'acculturation de
nos élèves au numérique ce qu'on appelle
aux états unis des humanités numériques
ya pas seulement apprendre à taper et à
chercher sur google mais à coder à avoir
des notions de gestion de projets de
design enfin vraiment d'aller en
profondeur dans ces nouvelles cultures
numériques qui sont qui nous paraissent
importantes à maîtriser pour pour être
demain adaptée aux défis économiques en
la matière sur donc je reviens l'ordre
initial donc sur le le
les questions du sénateur du sénateur
maurey évidemment il n'est pas question
de passer par pertes et profits le
travail considérable qui a été fait par
le sénat dans le cadre de la préparation
de la proposition de loi
bien entendu et c'est d'ailleurs la
raison pour laquelle vous êtes invités à
vous exprimer
à partir de vendredi et ça aura un
travail qui sera un travail continu peut
être interrompue pendant la trêve
estivale mais qui qui reprendra à la
rentrée pour nous conduire à définir la
feuille de route nous souhaitons bien
sûr prendre en compte tous les travaux
qui ont été faits jusqu'à présent parce
que nous considérons que le plan
national très haut débit tel qu'il a été
défini par le président gouvernement
n'est pas satisfaisant et il n'est pas
satisfaisant
vous l'avez très bien dit pour plusieurs
raisons première raison qui nous paraît
très importante c'est effectivement le
problème du pilotage il n'y a pas de
pilote dans l'avion aujourd'hui donc
nous nous souhaitons mettre en place un
pilotage national qui prendra la forme
d'un établissement public ou d'un ou
d'un gip oudin enfin pour l'instant la
forme juridique n'est pas encore définie
mais elle sera justement à discuter à
partir de vendredi
ça sera un sujet la déclinaison aussi
peut-être régional sera sera également à
discuter c'est la raison pour laquelle
également nous pensons que la question
du financement au delà du fonds ne se
pose plus tôt dans la crise dans la dent
dans la perspective plus générale de
cette instance de pilotage parce que
pour nous dans la conception que nous en
avons en tout cas avec nous allons
proposer à la discussion à partir de
vendredi
cette instance de pilotage à la pour
vocation à être une assistance à
maîtrise d'ouvragé pour les
collectivités locales qui déploient
leurs schémas de qui réfléchissent à
leurs schémas départementaux
d'aménagement numérique du territoire ou
à la conception de leur réseau ou à la
maîtrise d'ouvragé de leurs réseaux donc
il nous faudra de la compétence
technique d'ingénierie de très haut
niveau dans cette instance nationale
pour aider justement les collectivités
locales à définir leur leur cahier des
charges techniques et à des après a
assuré la maîtrise d'ouvragé des
investissements et vie parallèlement
cette cette instance nationale aura
vocation effectivement à gérer les
financements donc à la fois le volet
subventions et le volet
prêts aux collectivités locales si nous
parvenons à transformer ce guichet à
c'est notre souhait qui effectivement ne
pas mobiliser parce qu'il a été mal
conçu et à transformer ce guichet en
guichet de prêts aux collectivités
territoriales nous sommes en train
d'essayer haut en ce moment d'obtenir ce
résultat dans le cadre de la discussion
budgétaire donc donc problème tout de
pilotage national qui que nous
souhaitons régler très rapidement parce
que ça conditionne le début des travaux
tout simplement
ensuite la question mais un joint de le
dire du financement donc on a abordé la
question des subventions de public pour
l'instant le l'amendement qui était
abondamment état de 900 millions d'euros
est effectivement insuffisant pour
assurer le financement du plan du plan
très haut débit donc il nous faudra
réfléchir et ça fera aussi l'objet des
discussions que nous aurons avec vous à
partir de vendredi à la manière dont
nous pouvons mobiliser des financements
complémentaires alors des financements
européens donc là je réponds aussi l
simultanément à plusieurs questions qui
ont été posées sur sur l'accès à la fois
aux fonds structurels aux mécanismes
d'un mécanisme d'interconnexion et
également à la question des project
bonne mais je rajouterai aussi les
financements de la banque européenne
d'investissement qui ne faut pas oublier
et je pense que la structure que nous
créerons la structure nationale ou
vous-même collectivités territoriales
nous nous ferons en sorte qu'il y ait
une communication pour que vous puissiez
avoir accès aux prêts de la bei qui peut
financer qui peut participer à au
financement de cette info de ces travaux
d'infrastructure parce qu'elle peut
octroyer des crédits à des taux
avantageux pour des investissements de
long terme
donc nous essaierons de faire en sorte
de centraliser dans cette instance de
pilotage l'ensemble des financements qui
seront à la disposition des
collectivités pour déployer les réseaux
les réseaux de très haut débit
localement et puis ce qui nous paraît
effectivement très important vous l'avez
dit c'est qu'aujourd'hui les modèles
économiques ne sont absolument pas
sécurisé ni pour les collectivités mais
ni pour les opérateurs d'une certaine
façon
donc en réalité aujourd'hui les
collectivités locales n'ont absolument
aucune garantie que dans les zones non
denses des réseaux qu'elles seront
éventuellement amenés à déployer seront
utilisés par les
par les opérateurs et inversement
les opérateurs ont assez peu de
garanties que le déploiement sera dans
des conditions techniques qui leur
permettront de déployer ses services
donc aujourd'hui c'est pour ça que cette
instance nationale est absolument
essentiel il nous faut définir à
l'échelle nationale ce cahier des
charges technique en partenariat avec
les collectivités locales et avec les
opérateurs pour savoir quelles sont les
spécificités des réseaux qui permettront
d'assurer le déploiement des services et
aux opérateurs de garantir aux
collectivités qui se lanceront dans ses
investissements que leurs réseaux seront
rentables et qui leur permettront à qui
sont effectivement utilisées par par les
opérateurs
la question que que soulevait je sais
plus si c'est le sénateur maurey sur le
double le double double investissement
n'ont cessé me suffit c'est monsieur
fichier qui signalait que dans sa dans
sa région
france télécom en douce tirait des raids
et des fourreaux pour pour y installer
la fibre plus rapidement par la suite
n'ont effectivement je pense que là où
il est de notre rôle est en lien avec
l'arcep sans doute de demander aux
opéras d'exiger de la part des
opérateurs qu'on a une cartographie
exacte de l'existant parce
qu'effectivement dans certaines zones
le déploiement de la fibre peut
s'effectuer dans des fourreaux qui sont
déjà existants et il n'est pas question
de dupliquer ce est de dupliquer ses
fourreaux et de et de consacrer de
l'argent à dupliquer des infrastructures
qui sont déjà existantes
donc nous allons faire en sorte que les
opérateurs nous donne la cartographie
exacte de leur de leurs installations
pour que nous puissions le cas échéant
utiliser ses installations pour déployer
plus rapidement le
le très haut débit nous allons nous
instaurons une relation avec avec france
télécom des actionnaires un peu plus
viril que par le passé alors je ne sais
pas si j'avais connu à toutes les
questions du sénateur maurey non y avait
sept avec y avait la question sur le sur
le téléphone mobile
donc effectivement sur la téléphonie
mobile il ya la question de la de la
couverture des zones blanches
donc ce programme il est en cours et ils
associent pour le moment l'état que les
opérateurs et les collectivités locales
depuis 2003 il a déjà prêt permet de
couvrir quand même un certain nombre de
centres bourgs de deux communes puisque
je crois que 3083 commune est très
exactement ont été couvertes depuis 2003
ce qui correspond à 97,7 % du territoire
couvert alors évidemment il reste à
couvrir les les
les autres communes restantes elles sont
au nombre de 217 d'après ce que nous
savons
non vous compte vous pensez que c'est
plus que ça non mais c'est qu'il devait
redéfinir la mesure tutorat elle aime le
ministère tommy couverture on prend la
couverture au centre bourg et tous les
écarts ne sont pas comptabilisés ce qui
veut dire que d'accord une photographe
est je pense que la réponse à cette
question c'est bien plutôt effectivement
de rediscuter avec larsen la mesure de
la qualité de service et les critères
qui seront qui seront audités dans le
cadre de ses mesures de qualité de
service et ça nous pouvons effectivement
avoir une discussion avec l'autorité de
régulation pour pour vérifier avec elle
la pertinence des critères et je pense
que ça serait effectivement utile pour
ne pas donner une mauvaise définition de
la couverture en téléphonie mobile
voilà je crois que j'ai répondu à peu
près non à toutes les questions non
alors sur cieux alors monsieur
retailleau donc sur le sur le très haut
débit mobile et la question de la 4g
là effectivement vous avez souligne à
juste titre que les opérateurs se sont
engagés à déployer à chaque fois sur un
volet enfin sur un rythme assez
symétrique qui paritaire une antenne ou
une installation dans les centres villes
ou dans les villes ou dans les zones
denses et puis une dans les zones
prioritaires rural donc nous soyez
assurés que c'est une obligation
réglementaire donc nous veillerons à
faire en sorte que les opérateurs
respectent 7,7
cette obligation réglementaire nous y
serons nous y serons très vigilants
pour le moment les expérimentations
elles ont essentiellement elles ont
essentiellement pour objectif de nous
aider à mesurer les investissements que
nous allons devoir accomplir pour
nettoyer les bandes qui sont sur
lesquels il existe des brouillages avec
les fréquences de la tnt donc sont
vraiment des expérimentations qui ont
pour vocation à nous aider à des aa
procédé assez à ces investissements pas
tout puisque le canal qui est brouillé
c'est le canal du bas or le canal wifag
va durer et n'est pas utilisé pour des
grandes villes que j'ai cités tout à
l'heure donc il n'ya pas de brouillages
sur ces zones là non mais les fréquences
des fréquences pour l'instant qui ont
été ouverts pour la 4g sont des
fréquences 800 le seul le seul opérateur
qui est une fréquence une autre
fréquence qui sur une autre bande c'est
free pour l'instant et donc nous pour
l'instant la nôtre notre priorité c'est
de faire en sorte qu'elle a vendu 800
soit effectivement utilisable pour que
les les trois autres opérateurs sfr
bouygues et france télécom puisse
déployer déployer la 4g / sur cette
fréquence là sur le plan national très
haut débit encore est ce qu'il ya des
questions sur lesquelles je n'avais pas
répondu sur sur l'engagement des
opérateurs donc effectivement
nous souhaitons faire en sorte que les
opérateurs qui se sont manifestés sur
les zones amis soient plus contraints
par leur engagement qu'il ne l'était
dans la situation antérieure ou dans la
situation encore actuelle la question
des sanctions financières ou la section
là la question de la nature juridique de
l'engagement je pense que c'est quelque
chose dont il faudra qu'on en discute
lors de la table ronde qui aura lieu
vendredi
effectivement il faut faire en sorte que
les opérateurs soient contraints de
respecter leurs engagements nous nous
étions plutôt sur une ligne qui
consistait à avoir un observatoire
national qui serait sans doute piloté
par le établissements publics ou le gip
de pilotage nous souhaitons que dans le
cas de ceux de cette étape de ce
pilotage national il ya effectivement un
observatoire qui puisse permettre de en
toute transparence vis-à-vis à la fois
des consommateurs et des collectivités
locales de contrôler le rythme de
déploiement de désinvestissements et le
respect des engagements pris par les
opérateurs est en tout cas l'opérateur
le plus concerné étant l'opérateur
historique dans lequel l'état est
actionnaire je pense que nous aurons un
levier aussi pour faire en sorte que
qu'il respecte ses engagements et le
rappeler à l'ordre
fermement s'il ne sait si ce n'est pas
le cas donc je pense que ce sera en tout
cas nous ce que nous proposerons
vendredi sur le donc sur le guichet à ce
jeu j'ai répondu qu'effectivement nous
souhaitions convertir ce guichet en
guichet à la faveur des collectivités
locales sur l'europe
effectivement on nous a demandé la
commission nous a demandé d'émettre un
certain nombre de projets pour à la fois
les projets de bombes et le mécanisme
le mécanisme d'interconnexion et mia
européen
donc nous nous avons souhaité dans les
discussions que vous avez nous avons eu
à dans les conseil compétitivité et avec
les commissaires nous avons souhaité que
le fmi puisse permettre d'intervenir sur
les réseaux de collecte ce qui n'était
pas initialement prévu et donc je pense
que ça sera ce sera ce sera cela
pourrait être le cas mais il faut
aujourd'hui que les collectivités
puissent se manifester tant auprès de la
banque
l'abbé yeux que co près de nous pour que
nous puissions porter des projets
concernant les protège bones pour une
pulsion avoir accès à ces financements
parce qu'ils sont comme vous l'avez
souligné assez assez peu élevé
finalement pour 27 pays et donc nous
avons tout intérêt effectivement à nous
mobiliser collectivement pour faire
émerger des projets finançables et à les
présenter
alors pour l'abbaye ça peut être
collectivités locales directement à
l'abbaye où ça peut être porté par une
structure qui serait notre structure de
pilotage éventuellement auprès de auprès
de la banque de l'abbaye eux sur les
questions encore des financements et la
question de la taxe copé vous soulevez
un point effectivement très important
nous sommes très clairement exposé à une
remise en cause à la fin de l'année de
cette taxe copé qui va conduire l'état à
rembourser à peu près un milliard un peu
plus d'un milliard aux opérateurs un
mini à près d'un milliard cinq aux
opérateurs donc effectivement cette
circonstance complexifie un peu la
discussion qu'on peut avoir avec les
opérateurs aujourd'hui sur la mise à
contribution leurs mises à contribution
dans le cadre du financement du du des
investissements liés au très haut débit
donc nous allons essayer de trouver un
moyen intelligent de faire coïncider les
calendriers et de faire en sorte que
effectivement c'est la taxe copé qui
n'est pas eurocompatible
si donc cet axe copé est annulée que
nous puissions faire en sorte que une
taxe d'un montant équivalent peut-être
ou en tout cas une taxe sur les
opérateurs puissent venir la remplacer
et qu'elle serve à abonder les
financements destinés aux déploiements
des réseaux puisque là pour le coup ce
serait eurocompatible voilà donc pour
cette audition qui a eu lieu en début
d'après midi au sénat
prochain rendez vous de l'actualité
politique et parlementaire
le journal de 22 heures présentée par
pierre henri gergonne il reçoit
notamment ce soir alain vidalis le
ministre aux relations avec le parlement
vous pouvez bien sûr toujours retrouvées
les auditions et la séance sur notre
site publicsenat.fr
très bonne fin de journée sur les
chaînes parlementaires